we're on problem 31
a sewing club is making a quilt
consisting of 25 squares with each side
of the square measuring 30 centimeters
okay there's going to be 25 of these
and they're going to be 30 by 30.
if the quilt has five rows and five
columns what is the perimeter of the
quilt okay so let me draw that out
so let's say this is the has five rows
and five columns and they're all squares
so this the quilt itself is going to be
a square
has five rows so one
two
three
four and then five and then one
two
three
four so that's a five by five and each
of these squares their sides are 30
right
30 centimeters so how long is one side
of this quilt going to be well it's
going to be 30 times 5 right so it's
going to be 150 centimeters
same argument that's going to be 150
centimeters that's going to be 150
centimeters right 30 times 5
and this is going to be 150 centimeters
so the perimeter is 150 plus 150 plus
150 plus 150 and that's well that's 600
so that's choice c
the four sides of this figure will be
folded up and taped to make a box fair
enough
what will be the volume of the box okay
so there is if we cut this out right now
and we folded it
along where i'm drawing these green
lines we'll get a box and they want to
say you know what's the volume
well volume is just the base times the
height times the depth right so if i
were to fold up this box it's going to
look something like this you're going to
have the base
which is this base right here and this
is what one two three four five by one
two three four five so it's a five by
five base
and then each of the sides are going to
be too high if i fold this up it's going
to be too high like that
right if i were to do one two three or
it's going to look like that if i folded
that side up this side when i fold it up
is going to look like this
all right one two three four five that
side when i fold it up it's going to
look like that and that's how when i
fold this when i and this side when i
fold it up it's going to look like that
it's one two three four five the big
picture the width is five the depth is
five and the height is two so the volume
is five times five is twenty-five times
two
which is equal to fifty
and that's choice a
problem 33 let me
where's 33 i think it's on the next page
okay
okay let me copy and paste it
let's just copy and paste the whole test
okay it says a classroom globe has a
diameter of 18 inches if i were to go
from the center
to the side it's 18 inches
which of the following is the
approximate surface area in oh no sorry
i just drew the radius it has a diameter
of 18 inches this is 18
right
which of the following is an approximate
surface area in square inches of the
globe
and surface area they give us the
equation they give it in terms of the
radius right so if the diameter is 18
what's the radius the radius is half of
the diameter the radius is half of that
the diameter so the radius is equal to
and we just plug that into here so the
surface area is equal to 4 pi
times the radius squared times 9 squared
that equals
4 times 81 times pi all right 9 squared
is 81 so it's 3
24 pi
and when they actually multiplied it out
so let's see
let's see 4 times 81 is
4 times 80 is 320 and then we have 324
pi
and then if i were to guess this this is
going to be yeah i mean look at all the
choices
pi is
more than three
right so this value is going to be more
than three times 324. so it's going to
be around a thousand or a little bit
yeah a little bit more than a thousand
and the only one that's even close to
that is d
but if you wanted to
confirm that you could multiply
324 times
3.14
that is equal to 1017.4
all right next problem
problem 34 i'll copy and paste 34 and 35
at the same time
let's see
okay almost there all right
okay let me
there you go
then i put this there
and then
all right
ready to do it
the rectangle shown below has length of
20 meters and width of 10. so this is 10
and this is 20.
i just picked that because this looks
longer than that
fair enough that's a 10 i drew i know it
doesn't look like a 10. if the four
right if the four triangles are removed
from the tri rectangle as shown what
would be the area of the remaining
figure so what's the area before i
remove them it's 20 times 10 right
that's the area of the whole rectangle
so it's 200
and then how much area am i removing so
each of these triangles
what's its area it's base times height
times one-half that's the area of a
triangle
right because if you just did base times
height you'd be figuring out the area of
this of this little
rectangle there so the area of this is
four times four is 16 times one half
which is eight
this is going to be eight it's going to
be eight is going to be eight so we're
removing 4 8 from this area so we're
moving 32
so minus 32
and that's what 168
so that's choice c
problem 35 if
rstw
is a rhombus
okay rstw is a rhombus what is the area
so rhombus tells us that all the sides
are equal and they're parallel what is
the area of
x
t
the area of w x t
w so this right here
w x t
okay so this is something that you maybe
may or may not have learned about a
rhombus already but its diagonals
actually intersect
at a perpendicular line
and let me see what else we can
see this is 60 degrees
so this is 30 degrees
let's see what we can
get from this this is 12
then this is 12
right
oh okay i see where they're going with
this so if this is 90 degrees this is 90
degrees
this is 12 i mean it's a rhombus so all
the sides are the same
right
if this is 60 this is 90. this has to be
30 degrees
right this has to be 30 degrees and then
you could actually make a very
strong argument that these are similar
triangles whatever length this is this
that's the same length because this is a
parallelogram and the diagonals bisect
each other this slide is equal to that
side that side is equal to this side so
these are congruent triangles so this is
also going to be 60 degrees
this is going to be 30.
but if you have a 60 let me do it in
another color
if you have a 60
60 60 triangle all of the angles are 60
degrees you're dealing with an
equilateral triangle
so that tells you
that tells you that
all the sides are the same so if this
side is 12 that side is 12. this side
right here also has to be 12.
that side here also has to be 12.
if that whole side is 12 what's this
length we already know that in a
parallelogram the diagonals bisect each
other so this length is six
and this length is six
fair enough
and let's see if this length if each of
these lengths are six
can we figure out what this height is
equal to
because if we know the base and the
height we're regular we're ready to
figure out the area of a triangle
so let's see if we can use a pythagorean
if we call this x we could say x squared
plus 6 squared plus 36
is equal to 12 squared is equal to 144
and we could say that x squared is equal
to what's 1 144
minus 36 that's what 108 i want to say
let's see
yes 108 so x squared is equal to 108
x is equal to the square root of 108 and
i can simplify that more because see 9
goes into 108
right 9 goes into 108 12 times
right now let me do that so this is so x
is equal to the square root of 9 times
12 that's 108 so that's equal to the
square root of 9 times the square root
of
12. square root of 12. well square root
of 12 is see that's equal to
3 times the square root of 12 square
root of 12 is the same thing as square
root of 3 times the square root of 4
right square root of 4 is 2 so that's
2 times 3 is 6 square roots of 3 right
this is 36 times 3 we could have said
this is equal to the square root of 36
times the square root of 3. you can't
see what i just wrote there times the
square root of 3 right
all right so 6 square roots of 3 that's
this side
so what's the area of this triangle
right there it's one half
times this base times six
times six square roots of three
six square roots of three so that's one
half times six is three times six square
roots of three is 18 square roots of
three
now that's just this triangle
this triangle is congruent to this
triangle so it'll have the same area and
you can make the same argument that all
of these triangles are congruent so the
area of this entire rhombus is going to
be four times this
right if i
if i'm looking at it right it's going to
be four times is that what they wanted i
don't know they wanted the area of wxd
that's what we just figured out they
didn't want the area of the whole round
but they want just the area
of this triangle right there which is we
just which we just figured out which is
eighteen square roots of three
i'm trying to think if there's a simpler
way of doing this there might be some
formula for the equation for the area of
a rhombus that i've forgotten in my
memory but we were able to reprove it
and that's always better to actually
come come from basic principles anyway
i'll see you in the next video